the u.s president paid tribute to queen
elizabeth ii at the british embassy in
washington and then during a political
event
i had the opportunity to meet her before
she passed and she was an incredibly
gracious and decent woman
the thoughts and prayers of the american
people
are with the people of the united
kingdom and the commonwealth and their
grief
biden's remarks honored the special
relationship between a monarchy and its
one-time colony
ties rooted in cooperation during two
world wars
in all queen elizabeth hosted or visited
13 of the 14 post-war presidents
these weren't gatherings to plan global
economic or security agendas as head of
state the queen was barred from making
policy
these were opportunities to reaffirm the
u.s and uk's commitment to democracy
civility and human dignity
former u.s presidents including barack
obama bill clinton and donald trump
issued condolence statements
and ordinary citizens paid their
respects at the embassy including some
who shared the queen's affection for
corgis she also
helped
bring the idea of dogs into the home and
showed that dogs are not
just animals that belong on farms but
also they can belong in a royal palace
and and be part of be part of a family i
was lucky enough to like see her in like
three carriage rides
um
so even though it wasn't someone who's
like present in my life it's still
very upsetting to know that they're gone
but you know just i think she'd want us
to spread the love that she loves like
spread to her people so that's you know
why i'm up here as the flags at the
capitol and the white house were lowered
to half staff
the bells rang 96 times at the
washington national cathedral part of
the global anglican communion
a tribute to the woman who was both head
of the universal church and a beloved
grandmother figure to so many in the u.s
rosalyn jordan al jazeera